[Music]
I didn't expect all this this is crazy
Jennifer Lopez has added yet another job
to her resume shoe designer the
multi-talented star put her heart and
soul literally into her new capsule
collection with Giuseppe Zanotti it was
really cool was you named the shoes
after family members I think of family
and their my stability they keep me
grounded and I don't know there was a
connection there's always like you know
what I'm gonna name it after all the
women in my family this one here is the
Emmy this is Emmy this is named for my
little baby what's it about a gladiator
snakeskin she's she's soft and fierce
she is like the combination of
everything good in this world she liked
to walk around in mommy's heels she was
very little you just instagrammed a new
spanish-language album when are we going
to hear the new music I'm so excited
it's gonna be sooner rather than later
it's a beautiful album I love everybody
that I'm working with it collaborated
with Marc kinda nervous uh Marc is
executive producing it the whole album
we're working on it together and it's
it's been a great time for us
[Music]